welcome to free pilot training i'm josh
if you're looking for an excuse to throw
away your flight computer
and still make fight calculations you're
gonna love today's video this is also a
great excuse to purchase that calculator
watch you've always wanted
you know you want one
[Music]
not only will these skills eliminate
your need for a flight computer but
you're also going to find them really
useful for everyday flying i even use
them sometimes in the c130 even though
the plane makes a lot of calculations
for me
now the main calculations i want to
focus on today are time fuel and
distance calculations because these are
what you'll be using even after you get
your pilot's license but we'll discuss
how to make the other calculations that
you'll find on the flight computer as
well
when we're talking about calculating
time fuel and distance we're actually
talking about two different types of
calculations not three
we're trying to find the relationship
between distance and time and between
fuel and time
both of these types of calculations use
time as a system of measurement when we
talk about the rate at which we do
something we typically talk about hours
for example i'm driving 100 miles an
hour or i'm burning 10 gallons of gas
per hour but hours are really not a
small enough measurement to get accurate
numbers for flight so we typically use
minutes to calculate those things
now we all know that there's 60 minutes
in an hour so if we want to convert
between hours and minutes all we need to
do is multiply and divide by 60 and this
is what we call the sixty to one rule
we're simply changing things from hours
to minutes to make things simple let's
jump right in so you can see what i'm
talking about
the first calculation we're going to be
making today is to determine how fast
we're traveling
let's say we flew for two nautical miles
and it took us three minutes to get
there how fast are we going
okay so we want to know our speed in
relation to hours but what we have is
our speed in relationship to three
minutes well that's not useful for
anyone the first step in solving this
problem is to figure out how far we went
in one minute so if we want to figure
out how far that is we simply divide two
by three minutes
now we can see that in one minute we're
traveling 0.67 nautical miles
we're traveling about .67 nautical miles
a minute
well what about per hour
well there's 60 minutes in an hour so we
simply multiply by 60 to see that we're
traveling 40.2 nautical miles per hour
and this is the whole basis for the
sixty to one rule
the first step is always finding your
relationship to one minute
then the problem becomes a lot easier to
solve okay what if i flew 100 miles and
it took me 50 minutes to get there now
how fast am i going once again the first
step is to figure out how far we went in
one minute well a hundred miles divided
by 50 minutes is two so i'm traveling
two miles a minute and you probably
don't even need a calculator to see that
two miles a minute times 60 minutes is
120 miles per hour now you're starting
to see how easy this is but let's make
things a little bit harder
what if i want to know how long it will
take me to get somewhere let's say i'm
flying 110 knots and i'm traveling 130
nautical miles how long will my trip
take well
knots is 110 nautical miles per hour so
let's change that to minutes by dividing
by 60 so we're traveling 1.83 nautical
miles a minute now that i know that i
can see that all i have to do is divide
130 nautical miles by 1.83
to see that it should take us 71 minutes
to get there
by the way i'm doing a little bit of
rounding on all these calculations today
so if your numbers are slightly off
that's why but if i wanted to get these
numbers down to the nanosecond i could
do that if i wanted speaking of that
here's a great way to use this
calculation in the airplane for some
really quick pilot math let's say i'm
flying 118 knots ground speed and i've
got a 308 mile trip how long is that
going to take me
if i'm looking for a really quick answer
this is how i'd tackle the problem
you and i both know that two hours is
120 minutes so i can easily look at 118
and know that i'm traveling about two
nautical miles a minute even without
using a calculator
then 300 miles divided by two is 150
then eight minutes divided by two is
four so it's going to take me at least
154 minutes to get there and even with
all this rounding my quick calculations
are getting me within three minutes of
an exact answer and as you can see this
can come in really handy in the plane
when you need fast answers and i didn't
have to dig out my flight computer i use
a 61 rule for problems like this all the
time
now what if i want to know how far i
went let's say i'm traveling 80 knots
for 1 hour and 40 minutes how far did i
go
well how many nautical miles in a minute
are we traveling
80 divided by 60 is 1.33
so i'm traveling 1.33 nautical miles a
minute now how many minutes am i flying
for
one hour and 40 minutes is 100 minutes
so i simply multiply 100 minutes by 1.33
nautical miles a minute to see that i
traveled just over 133 miles
i didn't even need a calculator for that
part i just moved the decimal over what
if i'm traveling 90 knots and i flew for
1 hour and 10 minutes now how far did i
go
well i don't even need a calculator to
see that i'm traveling one and a half
nautical miles a minute because 90
divided by 60 is
1.5 an hour and 10 minutes is 70 minutes
and 70 times 1.5 is 105
so i'll travel 105 miles
next we're going to be talking about
calculating fuel and just like i
mentioned in the last video before we
can accurately make calculations we need
to check the poh to see how much fuel
per hour we can expect our airplane to
burn
okay so let's say our poh says we're
going to be burning 7.5 gallons per hour
what if i fly for 43 minutes how much
fuel will i use
just like our distance calculations we
need to change this number to minutes to
make things easier on us
so 7.5 gallons per hour divided by 60 is
0.125 gallons per minute now we can just
multiply that times 43 because we're
flying for 43 minutes
looks like we'll be using about 5.4
gallons of fuel
what if i'm burning 10 and a half
gallons per hour and i'm flying for 15
minutes looks like if we convert 10.5
gallons per hour over to minutes we're
going to be burning 0.175 gallons per
minute so in 15 minutes we will burn
2.625
gallons let's change this around a bit
let's say i have 32 gallons of fuel on
board and i'm burning 9 gallons per hour
how much flight time do i have
there are a few different ways to solve
this one but the easiest way is to
simply divide 32 gallons by 9 gallons
per hour and that gives us 3.56 hours so
if we want to turn 0.56 into minutes we
simply multiply that times 60
that gives us 33.6
so we'll have about 3 hours and 33
minutes of fuel on board now let's say i
flew to another airport with full tanks
and it took me 45 minutes to get there
when i landed i went ahead and topped
off the plane with more fuel and it took
7.5 more gallons
how many gallons per hour did i burn on
that trip
this one's a little bit tricky but if we
divide 7.5 by 45 we can see that we're
burning about 0.167 gallons per minute
if we multiply that times 60 minutes
you'll see that we're burning 10 gallons
per hour
okay now that you've seen these basic
calculations let's solve a couple cross
country problems let's say we're flying
across country from veneta municipal
over to branson west
after our departure we crossed our first
waypoint at 0 8 13 local time
then we flew over our second waypoint at
0 8 21 local
what time will we arrive at our
destination
before we can calculate anything we need
to find our distances
and we can do that by using our plotter
as you can see the distance between our
first waypoint and our second waypoint
is 13 nautical miles
and it looks like we have 50 miles to go
for the rest of the trip
if we subtract 813 from 821 you can see
that it took us 8 minutes to go 13 miles
so how many nautical miles a minute are
we going well if we divide 13 by 8 you
can see that we're traveling
1.625 nautical miles a minute
now you could multiply that times 60 to
get your ground speed of 97.5 knots but
we don't need to do that in order to
answer this question
all we need to do is divide our distance
remaining by our nautical miles per
minute so if we divide 50 miles by 1.625
we can see that it'll take us exactly
30.77 minutes to get there
and .77 of a minute is roughly 46
seconds
so we'll get there in 30 minutes and 46
if i want to know my time of arrival i
can simply add this time to the time of
my last waypoint which we said was 8 21
so you can see that we'll arrive at west
branson at 8 51 and 46 seconds
now how much fuel will we burn for the
rest of the trip
well if the poh tells us we're burning
8.2 gallons per hour let's change that
to minutes really quick
8.2 divided by 60 would mean that we're
burning 0.137 gallons per minute and
that means we're going to burn 4.22
gallons of fuel before we land let's do
another one really quick
let's say we're flying back and we pass
our first waypoint at 0 9 14 local and
we pass our second waypoint at 9 22.
this leg is 10 miles and we have 51
miles to go now what time will we arrive
at our destination
as you can see if we subtract 914 from
922 this leg took us 8 minutes as well
we must have a bit of a headwind now
anyway let's see how many miles per
minute we're going remember all we have
to do is divide our distance by our time
so we can divide 10 by 8 to see that
we're going 1.25 nautical miles a minute
now we simply divide our distance
remaining of 51 miles by 1.25 nautical
miles a minute to see that will arrive
in 40.8 minutes so that's 40 minutes and
48 seconds
let's add that to 922 and you can see
that will arrive at 1002 and 48 seconds
i changed my power setting for the route
back
now my poh says i'll burn 8.4 gallons
per hour
if i divide that by 60 you can see that
i'm burning 0.14 gallons per minute
multiple life at times are 40.8 minutes
and you can see that will burn
5.712 gallons for the remainder of this
trip now based on my calculations at
this waypoint i had 10 gallons of fuel
remaining
am i going to be legal to continue this
flight to my destination or should i
consider diverting well we know it's
daytime because of the time so we need
to land with 30 minutes of fuel
we're burning 8.4 gallons per hour so we
need to have half of that when we land
so we need 4.2 gallons in the tank when
we land okay so we have 10 gallons in
the tank and we're going to burn 5.712
gallons the rest of the way
that means we'll land with
4.288 gallons of fuel so to answer our
question will we be legal
yes but barely and you should never be
cutting it that close but you never know
the situations that you could get into
so it's good to be able to make these
calculations because of that it's smart
to continue practicing making
calculations like this because after you
get your license you will need to use
them in flight occasionally
now here's something a lot of people
don't know
you can actually make your win
calculations without a flight computer
as well and while it's a little easier
to learn how to use the wiz wheel to
make these calculations once you learn
how to do this you can use this method
to make quick estimates that are fairly
accurate and save you from having to dig
out that flight computer in flight as
you know by now if there's no wind the
ground track or magnetic course your
airplane is flying will be the same as
your heading
minus deviation
in addition to that your ground speed
will also equal your true air airspeed
but as you and i both know there is
always wind
without a flight computer one way you
can determine your wind correction angle
and your ground speed is by using a wind
triangle or vector analysis let's say
you want to fly a true course of one
zero zero and you're planning on flying
at 85 knots true air speed
you looked at the winds aloft and it
looks like the winds are going to be 0 6
0 at 15 knots
to solve this problem you need two
simple tools a protractor like you use
in middle school and a plotter
the first thing we need to do is lay the
protractor out on your chart in a line
with true north remember lines of
longitude all run directly north and
south so let's draw a line here going
north and south so it's easier to see
and i'll go ahead and label these to
make it army proof
now we know our winds are 0 6 0 at 15
knots so let's draw a line from the 60
degree mark through the center of the
protractor and this needs to extend past
the other side a little ways and you'll
see why here in just a second
next let's pull out our plotter and make
a mark from the intersection of those
marks down that wind line 15 nautical
miles because our wind speed is 15 knots
once we do that we can take the plotter
and place one end on that mark and place
the other end on your true cores
you want the true cores to intersect the
true air speed you're expecting on the
plotter
in this example i'm expecting 85 knots
so i'll make a mark here on my true
course
then i'll draw a line between these two
points from here if i want to know my
ground speed all i need to do is measure
our true course line back from our
intersection over to that mark where our
vector line intersects
i'm reading 72 knots ground speed here
how about you
now that we've done that this line
represents our true heading we need to
fly to keep our airplane on our true
course now to find out what that heading
is we need to pull our protractor back
out to make this a little easier let's
zoom in on where these two lines
intersect and when we lay the protractor
down you can see that our wind
correction angle is about seven degrees
and as you can probably tell that seven
degrees we need to point our nose to the
left to keep us on our true course of
one zero zero
and as you know the numbers on a compass
get smaller as we turn to the left so
all we need to do is subtract 7 from 100
to get our true heading of 093 degrees
but don't forget to include that
magnetic variation in your calculations
today we'll say mine is 2 degrees east
so i'll subtract that to get a magnetic
heading of 091 degrees
and as you can see we got our ground
speed our wind correction angle our true
heading and our magnetic heading without
even pulling out a flight computer
and i think that's pretty cool
let's do one more of these with a
tailwind so you can see the difference
this time we're flying a true course of
082 with a true air speed of 80 knots
and our winds are 234 at 15 knots once
again we'll draw our north south line
and label them for our army guys my
marine friends probably need this too
anyway from here it's kind of weird
because this protractor doesn't have a
back side but that's okay i can do a
little math here to see that the
reciprocal of that number is 54 degrees
and i'll draw my line like it's trying
to push my airplane over to the other
side of that course
then we'll grab that plotter and make
our mark 15 knots from there
i'll draw my vector line using my true
air speed just like i did before
this time my true air speed is 80 knots
now our wind triangle is complete
let's grab our ground speed by measuring
our true course again from our north
south intersection over to this one
and it looks like i don't have enough
plotter for this job so i'll just grab
another one and now i'm reading about 92
knots ground speed
let's zoom in a little bit and grab our
wind correction angle
i'm getting 5 degrees to the right on
this one so i need to add 5 degrees to
my true course when i fly to get a true
heading of 087 degrees and once again
we'll subtract our easterly variation to
get a mag heading of 085
now while this method takes a tiny bit
more work than a flight computer in the
beginning using this method will allow
you to see how your wind speed and
direction affects your heading in your
ground speed
and you can actually get really accurate
estimating your ground speed and heading
with just a tiny bit of practice
so try this method a couple times and
see if you like it
let's go back and look at conversions
for a minute
to completely eliminate the need for a
flight computer there are a couple more
things you should know how to do first
you need to know how to find density
altitude and as i mentioned in the past
you need to find your pressure altitude
first and even the old wiz will doesn't
do that for you to find that you need to
know your field elevation and the
current altimeter setting
let's say your field elevation is 732
feet and the current altimeter is 2892
to find your pressure altitude all you
need to do is take the standard
altimeter setting which is
29.92 inches of mercury and subtract the
current altimeter setting from that now
keep in mind sometimes this number will
be negative and that's completely normal
in this example our answer is 1.00
now because the pressure in our
atmosphere drops one inch of mercury
every thousand feet let's turn this into
thousands by moving the decimal over
three places
it looks like we need to add a thousand
to 732 feet to get a pressure altitude
of
1732 feet if this number was negative
then i would subtract that from the
field elevation instead
okay so now that we know our pressure
altitude let's find density altitude the
easiest way to do this without a fly
computer is to use a spaghetti chart
like this
this one comes from the pilot's handbook
of aeronautical knowledge which you can
actually download for free from the
faa's website or you can get the book
pretty cheap from amazon as well i'll
put links to those in the description
you also find these a lot in newer pohs
so now you can see that the only two
things we need to find density altitude
are pressure altitude and the current
temperature let's say that the current
temperature is 35 degrees celsius and we
just said that our pressure altitude was
feet so let's find 35 degrees down here
at the bottom and move up until we hit a
pressure altitude of 1732
as you can see we kind of have to guess
where that is and we simply move over to
find our density altitude of about 4500
feet now there is a way to solve this
without one of these charts you can use
this formula too if you want
i'll do this really quick for you but no
one's going to expect you to know how to
do this so we've got a pressure altitude
here
this is our outside air temperature
which we said was 35 degrees and this
iso temp is the standard air temperature
at altitude remember standard
temperature at sea level is 15 degrees
celsius and the temperature drops 2
degrees every thousand feet so if our
pressure altitude is 1732
standard temperature there is about 12.3
not 15 degrees
okay so let's do this math really quick
35 minus 12.3 is 22.7
multiply that times 120 to get 2724
and we'll just add that to 1732
to get
so our exact density altitude is
4456 feet and this is what you're going
to be using to calculate the performance
of your airplane
as you can see our density altitude
chart was pretty close but if you're
trying to get exact numbers for some
reason this is the way to go
okay so another thing you might want to
convert is true and calibrated air speed
now i'm going to be the first one to
admit to you that if you want to be
precise all the formulas you're going to
find are way too complicated you're much
better off using a flight computer to
get the numbers perfect but here's a
quick wag that'll get you pretty close
for every thousand feet of altitude that
you gain you can generally expect your
true air speed to be about two knots
faster than calibrated air speed
for example let's say i'm flying at 120
knots true at an altitude of 5000 feet
every thousand feet of altitude i'll add
two knots so let's multiply two times
five because we're flying at 5000 feet
and that gives us 10 knots
now we said our true air speed was 120
knots so we simply subtract 10 from 120
and that gives us 110 knots calibrated
air speed if we knew our calibrated air
speed but not our true air speed we'd
simply add this number instead
for example if my calibrated air speed
was 100 knots then i'd add 10 to that to
see that i'm going about 110 knots true
let's do one more of these really quick
let's say i'm flying at 10 000 feet
pressure altitude at 90 knots calibrated
10 times 2 is 20 so we're looking at a
difference of 20 knots
we know our calibrated air speed is 90
knots so our true air speed should be
about 110 knots what if we are flying at
130 knots true
well in that case we'd simply subtract
this number in that case our calibrated
air speed would be about 110 knots now
once again if you pull out the flight
computer you're going to notice that
these numbers aren't perfect but this is
one of the best methods out there to get
you a quick estimation without a flight
computer
the last thing you'll find on an e6b is
a way to convert between true and
calibrated altitude now as you may
remember this is important because the
altitude you read on your altimeter may
be slightly different than the altitude
you're actually at because temperature
and air pressure can affect the readings
on your altimeter now while it is
possible to convert between true
altitude and calibrated altitude with a
little bit of math the best method out
there is to find this chart in section 7
of the aim while this chart doesn't give
you precise numbers you can use it to
see how low you could potentially be
below what your altimeter is actually
reading
notice up here the numbers across the
top indicate your height above the
ground or agl
so if i'm flying a thousand feet agl and
the temperature is negative 10 degrees
my indicated altitude could be as low as
100 feet below my true altitude so if my
altimeter reads 1500 feet msl and
there's a tower ahead of me at 1 450
feet in this hill my altimeter may tell
me that i'm going to clear it but if the
temperature is negative 10 degrees i'm
probably not going to be able to clear
it so while you typically don't need to
convert between true altitude and
calibrated altitude this chart is the
perfect tool to print out and put on
your knee board if you're concerned
about cold weather affecting your
indicated altitude because true altitude
doesn't change
i hope you learned something today in my
next video i'm going to do something a
lot more fun i plan on flying an actual
cross-country and only using pilotage
and dead reckoning with a navlog to do
it i'll put that video right here when
it's available you're really going to
enjoy that one i'll see you over there